hello and welcome to another 3abn today
Bible q a I'm Jason Bradley and I'm so
glad that you are joining us because I
know that you must have some questions
that are burning in your mind or burning
on your heart that you want answered
from the word of God and that is what we
are going to do on this program if you
haven't submitted your questions yet I
want to share with you how you may do so
you can text your questions to
618-228-3975 again that's
618-228-3975 or you may email your
questions to bibleqa at
3abn.tv again that's Bible QA at
3abn.tv and if you're on Instagram send
us a direct message at 3abn underscore
official again that's 3abn underscore
official now let me ask you a question
and I clearly I'm not going to hear your
answer right now unless you email me but
when you walk into a dark room and you
need to see something what do you do you
flip the light switch right you turn on
the light Psalm chapter 119 verse 105
says your word is a lamp to my feet and
a light to my path perhaps you've been
walking around in darkness and you want
to walk in the light get into God's word
get into his word and he will illuminate
your path for sure I want to welcome our
wonderful Bible students that we have
here we have Daniel Perrin it's great to
have you on thank you Jason it's good to
be here yes and next to you we have
brother John denzi it's great to have
you here with us well it's a blessing to
be here it's been a while been traveling
to different places by God's grace we
are here amen and Pastor John Loma Kang
Uncle loamy I know that you're going to
have some great answers from the word of
God for us today yes every time we open
the Bible we discover something that we
are yet to learn and God's word is
inexhaustible amen praise the Lord for
that amen one of the great challenges of
this program is confining those answers
to three minutes or four minutes that's
right and uh that can be very difficult
before we dive into the word of God
let's go to the to the Lord in prayer
John will you pray for us sure
our wonderful and loving Heavenly Father
we are grateful to you because the holy
scriptures that you have given are able
to make us wise unto salvation
and there's a blessing for him who
readeth and studies the word
so we ask Lord that as we
dive into the holy scriptures your holy
spirit will use us we pray that every
word will come from your throne of grace
and that we will have a better
understanding of the scriptures that you
have given to us we pray for a blessing
upon all those that join us wherever
they may be in this world and we pray
that you will continue to bless three of
the end to bring light and the truth of
your word to the whole world we ask in
Jesus holy and blessed name amen amen
amen Daniel I'm going to come to you
with this first question here I love
listening to music and watching good TV
programs but I tend to condemn myself
thinking that I am not supposed to be
doing so I worry that God is not able to
work with me because I promise to cut
back on my watching but I don't am I
addicted or am I judging myself too
harshly I told God I will give it up if
I know for sure I'm in the wrong this is
from Gene out of Oregon okay Gene there
were a lot of questions built in there
and they all revolve around the idea
that I want to be led by God and I want
to know that I'm doing God's Will and
one of the areas where we think about
God's will is what we do with our time
what should a Christian watch what
should a Christian read and so I invite
you to study the principles in two
verses here and add others to them and
really ask God to help you with these
principles Philippians 4 verse 8 that we
all know and are familiar with finally
Brethren whatever things are true
whatever things are noble whatever
things are just whatever things are pure
whatever things are lovely whatever
things are of good report if there is
any virtue if there is anything
praiseworthy then meditate on these
things
then the second verse to add to that is
Colossians 3 verse 2 if then you were
raised with Christ seek those things
which are above where Christ is seated
at the right hand of God sets your mind
on things above not on things of the
Earth
as we draw closer to Jesus coming we
want to know that our thoughts are more
and more and more consumed with him we
want to be learning ever learning every
day how to put into practice the things
that Jesus has taught us we want
everything that goes into our bodies and
our minds to prepare us for the
spiritual and physical tests of faith
that lie ahead and we want to know that
we are thinking more and more of
heavenly things and Desiring them and
loving them above anything else
and so ask yourself questions like these
does this song does this book does this
movie show or does this app on my phone
does it Draw Me Closer to Jesus really
be honest with that question there does
it make me think more about him when I
participate in this does it equip me
with the spiritual gifts and power to
resist temptation when I when I read
this or watch this does it lead me to
desire the word of God more and when I'm
done watching I can't wait to get into
God's word does it strengthen my ability
to rightly understand the word of God
and then to share it with others God has
given us this time in our life right now
to prepare for uh what is coming and so
we want to put into our minds the things
that will strengthen us
so the question may not be about whether
this is a good or bad thing to watch or
to read but am I really Desiring what is
the best thing to watch or to read do I
love his word can I not wait to come
back to it are my habits of Bible study
prayer and service growing stronger can
I say like job did in chapter 23 verse
12 I have treasured the words of his
mouth more than my necessary food we
want in everything we do to be growing
closer to Christ and so that's the
principle that I would invite you to
look at does this Draw Me Closer to
Jesus
I love that that's a great great thing
to do does it Draw Me Closer to Jesus
excellent uh brother Johnny
can you please explain Jeremiah chapter
31 verses 31 through 34 and Hebrews
chapter 8 verses 7 through 13. it
appears that God's covenant is with the
nation of Israel only because they are
the first fruits however Gentiles have
been grafted into the Olive Tree as
stated in Romans chapter 11. please
explain this comes from Tony out of New
Jersey
those are a lot of verses to go through
in a short amount of time but when you
look at Jeremiah chapter 31 verses
31-34 in essence is saying practically
the same thing in Hebrews chapter 8
verses 7 through 13.
and it talks about a new covenant and
there in Jeremiah chapter 31 verse 31 it
says behold the days are coming says the
Lord when I will make a New Covenant
with the house of Israel and with the
house of Judah and so when you go to
Hebrews chapter 8 you see the same
wording uh specifically in verse 10 for
this is the Covenant that I will make
with the house of Israel after those
days says the Lord I will put my laws in
their mind and write them on their
hearts and I will be their God and they
shall be my people uh yes it does use
the word first fruits in the context of
these two passages of scripture
concerning the people of Israel but we
must keep in mind that uh for example
John chapter 1 verses 10 through 13
Jesus said it says there he was in the
world and the world was made through him
and the world did not know him he came
to his own and his own did not receive
him but as many as received him to them
he gave the right to become the children
of God to those who believe in his name
who were born not of blood nor of the
will of the flesh nor of the will of man
but of God so we have in the New
Testament speaking to us about those
that accept Jesus Christ they are
children of God just as the children of
Israel who are considered the children
of God and it's not just that you're
born in Israel and now you're a child of
God you must be a believer you must
follow the Lord with all of your heart
and so Galatians chapter 3 verse I'm
going to go to verse 7 and 8. therefore
know that only those who are of Faith
are the sons of Abraham and the
scripture foreseen that God would
justify the Gentiles by faith preach the
gospel to Abraham beforehand saying in
you all the nations shall be blessed so
then those who are of Faith are blessed
with believing Abraham so in the context
of this we understand that in essence
the people that accept the Lord Jesus
Christ are part of spiritual Israel
being a part a part of spiritual Israel
you have the right to the New Covenant
that is writing the law in your heart
and in your mind let's take a look here
in Galatians chapter 3 verses 26 through
29. I'll try to finish that for you are
all sons of God through faith in Christ
Jesus for as many of you as were
baptized into Christ have put on Christ
there's neither Jew nor Greek there's
neither slave nor free there is neither
male nor female for you are all one in
Christ Jesus that's right and if you are
Christ then you are Abraham's seed and
heirs according to the promise so we see
here that uh when you talk about
Gentiles and Jews this has been
eliminated by the sacrifice that Jesus
Christ has made and as many as receive
him can become sons of God so I now
uh close with Romans chapter 11 and
notice what it says in verse 16.
powerful it says for if the first fruit
is Holy the lump is also holy and if the
root is Holy so are the branches so
Gentiles quote unquote grafted in are
also holy so we thank God for his
excellent mercy and his amazing grace
that all those who are here in my voice
can become a part of spiritual Israel
and I encourage you to make your
decision for Christ while there's time
and the sacrifice of Christ has made us
all one I praise the Lord for that amen
thank you thank you Pastor lonely King
when Adam and Eve were in the garden how
did they know what death was this is
from Anita
thank you Anita for the question well
they didn't really actually know what
death was but they were warned of the
possibility of death
but they had not experienced it there
was no death in creation yet we find in
Genesis 2 and verse 17 God warned Adam
specifically he says
but of the tree of the knowledge of Good
and Evil you shall not eat for in the
day that you eat of it you will surely
die this was clearly delineated
and as I insert before I go any farther
is that there are certain things that
God is saying to us it's not necessary
to know you know some people say well
knowledge is power well not in all cases
in this case the knowledge of sin was
not power the knowledge of death was not
power it was the disabling of power the
power that God had already given to them
God created them in His image after his
likeness and death would take that away
as we've seen the story there in the
Book of Genesis so you find this this
this clear communication you can die
when you disobey the result will be
death that's why the serpent knowing
that they had not experienced death yet
said you will not surely die Genesis 3
and verse 4 and it's amazing today that
that lie still exists thousands of years
later there are people that believe that
you die but not surely you're not really
dead and that's where we get this
continual belief that we people die but
they're not really dead
but the Bible says Adam lived 930 years
and he died so what happened that day
when Adam sinned
a door was open Romans 5 verse 12 the
door was open they did not understand
death they'd not experience it they had
not none of the plants died all creation
was in his perfection
loved to have been there in the perfect
creation one day we will by God's grace
but Romans 5 12 says therefore just as
through one man sin and to the world and
death through sin and thus death spread
to all men because all sinned so this
door was opened and then Adam and Eve
now became subject to death that's why
he only lived 930 years can you imagine
guys
930 years what can you do in 930 years
well I thought about that that was a
that was not a time of great joy for
Adam it was a time of seeing what his
decision had done can you imagine being
around watching first your wife dies
platin doesn't take say the year she
died but you lay your wife to rest then
you see Generations being affected by
death you see the animals change their
attitude towards you you see creation
dying and you realize just one decision
impacted creation at such a deep level
but here's the good news Revelation 21
verse 4. and God will wipe away every
tear from their eyes there shall be no
more death
so what entered creation will one day
itself pass away death spread as the
King James version death passed to all
one day death itself is going to pass
away and there will be no more death and
we will no longer know death anymore
amen for that amen
Daniel where in the Bible does it say
that Noah preached for 120 years this is
from Brian all right thank you for the
question Brian and nowhere in the Bible
are we explicitly told that Noah
preached for 120 years but here is what
the Bible does say in Genesis chapter 6
verse 3 and the Lord said my spirit
shall not strive with man forever for he
is indeed flesh yet his days shall be
120 years
and so uh God here is indicating a time
frame that the mercy that he has
extended to sinful man and the sin has
grown immense is going to be extended no
longer than 120 years this is not
referring to life spans because we know
that even those After the flood lived
much longer than 120 years and lifespans
did not get down to 120 years for about
a thousand years about the time of Moses
After the flood so as with each of the
judgments of God God gives warning
through His prophets which he had been
doing through the righteous Generations
leaving leading up to Noah now God could
have sent the flood immediately and
saved by any means he chose by snatching
people out but God gives time for
warning and the making of decisions and
that warning came through Noah Genesis
chapter 6 verses 13 to 21 is God's
instructions to Noah and in the middle
of that section Verse 18 He says you
shall go into the ark you your sons your
wife and your son's wives with you now
God is Not excluding the opportunity
here of others to be saved but God is
actually speaking prophetically to Noah
who at this point does not have any
children that you will have sons and
there will be generations to follow you
after the flood and those Generations we
know are the promise that leads up to
the Messiah Jesus our savior
so did Noah preach during that time of
Warning Second Peter chapter 2 verse 5
says that God did not spare the ancient
world but saved Noah one of eight people
a preacher of righteousness and one
thing I know about preachers is they're
going to preach
this is the way God works he sends his
message through people over 400 times in
the Bible through God's prophets we hear
these words thus says the Lord now how
did Noah preach well if I were to say I
preached for three weeks I don't mean
that I talked non-stop for three
straight weeks but during the time of
three weeks I spent time preaching and
so Noah during that 120 years spent time
preaching not only by his words but also
by his actions listen to Hebrews 11
verse 7. by faith Noah being divinely
warned of things not yet seen moved with
Godly fear prepared an ark for the
saving of his household by which he
condemned the world it was his actions
of Faith saying this world is passing
away my hope is in God that it was a
condemnation to those around him so his
preaching was done both through words
and through demonstration and Jesus says
that the time of Noah is an illustration
of a time leading up to his coming and
we have the same task by demonstration
the Holy Spirit working in our lives in
our own words to say salvation is in
Jesus Christ alone today
amen amen amen
preacher is the going to preach I like
that right
John densey Jesus was without sin so why
was he baptized
that is indeed a good question so let's
go ahead and go to for the sake of those
that may be not familiar with the
scriptures you find in Matthew chapter 3
verses 13-15 uh the the account of Jesus
being baptized then Jesus Came From
Galilee to John at the Jordan to be
baptized by him and John tried to
prevent him saying I need to be baptized
by you and that you coming to me
but Jesus answered and said to him
permitted to be so now for thus it is
fitting for us to fulfill all
righteousness then he allowed him so for
to fulfill all righteousness Jesus was
baptized did he have any sin no the
scripture is very clear and you have
also mentioned this as so notice Acts
chapter 2 verse 38 it's true people were
baptized to receive or to enter into the
realm of being forgiven by God Acts 2 38
then Peter said to them repent and let
every one of you be baptized in the name
of Jesus Christ for the remission of
sins and you shall receive the gift of
the Holy Spirit true it is found in
Hebrews chapter 4 beginning in verse uh
well I'll just reverse 15 and 16 15 and
16 for we do not have a high priest who
cannot sympathize with our weaknesses
but was in all points tempted as we are
yet without sin let us there for come
boldly to the throne of grace that we
may obtain mercy and find Grace to help
in time of need so why was Jesus
baptized if he had no sin
I'd like to quote a scripture to you
that it was to fulfill our righteousness
he left us an example that we should
follow not because he needed to be
baptized but he left us an example to
follow and I'm going to quote to you
from John 13 verse 14 and 15 and 16 and
17 will also be snuck in there and if if
I then your Lord and Master have washed
your feet you also ought to wash one
another's feet for I had given you an
example that you should do as I have
done to you verily verily I say unto you
the servant is not greater than his Lord
neither he that is sent greater than he
that sent him if you know these things
happy are you if you do them so I am
using this time when Jesus watched the
disciples feet to show you did he need
to wash the disciples feet he did but
did he need to be baptized no because he
had no sin but just as he left us an
example in washing the disciples feet
and asked them to do the same thing as
he has done he's asking us to be
baptized because we really need to be
baptized and so I also bring to you the
possibility I think it's uh that Jesus
was also baptized for the sake of those
that do not have the opportunity to be
baptized there are people they know they
learn about the Lord
in a time when they cannot be baptized
because of some sickness they cannot go
get out of the bed and get in the water
you have the thief on the cross he
couldn't come down from the cross and be
baptized so it is possible that his
baptism stands as a baptism for them
I'm so glad that you know Jesus leads by
example that's beautiful Pastor Wilma
King for he who speaks in a tongue does
not speak to men but to God for no one
understands him however in the spirit he
speaks Mysteries First Corinthians
Chapter 14 verse 2. what does this
scripture mean especially in the spirit
he speaks Mysteries mean sure sure let
me thank you for the question by the way
I always enjoy this particular question
because there are a number of things
that Paul deals with in the book of
First Corinthians chapter 14 is which is
preceded by chapter 13 which is preceded
by chapter 12. in the book of chapter
First Corinthians chapter 12 he talks
about the gifts chapter 13 He talks
about these gifts without the power of
God's love meaning absolutely nothing
and it begins by saying though I speak
with the tongues of men and of angels
what he was talking about there is not
that there's an Angelic tongue there's a
tongue that men speak in but he's
talking about do I speak with the common
language of man or the eloquence of very
well-trained men and so Paul continues
to deal with in a City Port where there
are multiple languages Paul Now talks
about those who have this gift and the
proper use of it let's first address
Mysteries you find in the gospels
continually this phrase talked about as
far as Mysteries are concerned let me
give you an example Colossians 1 verse
26 and 27 the mystery which has been
hidden from ages and from Generations
but now has been revealed to his Saints
to them God will to make known what are
the riches of the glory of this mystery
among the Gentiles which is Christ in
you the hope of glory there are many
Mysteries that the spirit of God
revealed to people at particular times
throughout history and the Corinthian
Church was no exception to that there
are many truths that Paul the Apostle
through his life revealed that were
hidden but the Holy Spirit as Jesus said
to his disciples there are many things I
want to say to you now but you can't
bear them but they were revealed in time
through the New Testament Church and
they were often referred to as Mysteries
even in the Old Testament we find in
Deuteronomy 29 29 the secret things
belong to the Lord Our God but those
things which are revealed belong to us
and to our children until it was
revealed it was a mystery so this is not
some mysterious we're not talking about
mysterious languages and mysterious
tongues so now let's go to First
Corinthians Chapter 14 verse 2. now
verse 2 is the isolated verse but verse
2 is not isolated in the chapter it's
just a part of the full picture let's go
to verse 2. for he who speaks in a
tongue
does not speak to men but to God for no
one understands him however in the
spirit he speaks Mysteries so Paul is in
essence saying the context is who
doesn't understand him let's continue
reading because he makes it extremely
clear let's go down to verse six and he
talks about he says I speak with more
tongues than all of you Paul made that
very clear in other words he's not
saying I'm speaking more mysterious
unknown languages he's simply saying I
have the ability to speak in many
languages look at verse 6 but now
Brethren if I come to you speaking with
the tongue what shall I profit you
unless I speak to you either by
Revelation by knowledge by prophesying
or by teaching
even things without life whether fluid
or harp when they make a sound unless
they make a distinction in the sound how
will it be known what is piped or what
is played let me go right to verse 9. so
likewise you unless you ought to buy the
tongue words easy to understand how will
it be known what is spoken for you will
be speaking into the air but watch this
verse 10 there are in it may be so many
kinds of languages in the world and none
of them is without significance verse
11. therefore if you do not know the
meaning of the language I shall be a
foreigner a barbarian to him who speaks
and he who speaks will be a foreigner or
Barbarian to me so verse 13 says
therefore let him who speaks in a tongue
pray that he may interpret
so here's the key and then he goes on
later on to say if there is no
interpreter let him keep silent Paul was
not speaking about ethereal
understandings the first place that
tongues are talked about being used in
the New Testament churches in Acts
chapter 2 and it says how be it that we
hear men speaking in our own language
where we were born the only time you
find that there's a language used that
men cannot use is in Romans chapter 8
verse 26 likewise the spirit also helps
our weaknesses for we do not know what
we should pray for as we ought but the
spirit himself makes intercession for us
with groanings which cannot be uttered
so the spirit of God intercedes in a way
that men cannot utter it that's the only
time the Bible speaks about the spirit
having a language we cannot utter it I
say again we cannot utter it but when
Paul is talking about he's simply
talking about languages speak in a
language if it's not to the people that
are listening make sure that there's an
interpreter amen thank you for clearing
that up that's a very very popular
question and we don't want you to feel
left out at home if you haven't
submitted any questions we want you to
send your questions to
618-228-3975 again text us your
questions at
618-228-3975 or email them to bibleqa at
3abn.tv again that's Bible QA at
3abn.tv and you can always send us a
direct message on Instagram at 3abn
underscore official again that's at 3abn
underscore official all right Daniel is
it wrong to encourage others to work on
the Sabbath for our convenience of going
to church
thank you for that question as I read it
there were several different ways to
understand it and I want to kind of
share how I understood the question to
be worded is it wrong to try to convince
someone to take my shift to work on the
Sabbath and by so doing will I be
convincing them to break God's law just
to keep my conscience clear and thinking
of the wording of the question I know
that the Sabbath is not a matter of
convenience but a matter of conviction
and loyalty and love of God in fact it
might be more convenient to not to have
to find somebody to replace you at work
so looking at the fourth Commandment and
what it says here it says in it you
shall not do any work you nor your son
nor your daughter nor your male servant
nor your female servant nor your cattle
nor your stranger who is within your
Gates and we know who you is not to do
any work can we know who your son or
daughter is not to do any work male or
female servant we don't really have that
as much in the same way except that
these would be people under your
influence that you assigned to them
their work duties uh people you hire
directly to work for you in your home or
something like that and isn't it great
that God even cares about your work
animals and so far none of these really
applies to a co-worker who makes their
own decisions about the work hours they
accept but who is The Stranger Within
your Gates biblically speaking these are
the foreigners who when Israel left
Egypt they attached themselves to Israel
Exodus 12 38 speaks about a mixed
multitude they'd seen God's power they
had experienced in a limited way His
blessings and they wanted to be with
Israel and be under the law of God and
so Leviticus 24 22 says you shall have
the same law for the stranger and for
the one of your own country for I am the
Lord your God and so these are people
who by the conviction of their
conscience by choice want to be under
God's law and so do not Place upon them
any uh duties that would require them to
choose between loyalty to God and Define
your Authority or loyalty to you the
standard of God's law is that you should
do what you know God God it Wills for
you you're not the one responsible for
other people's work or their choices to
not work especially those who don't see
any value or the same value in the
Sabbath would it be better for them to
come to know the truth of God through
you yes absolutely it would and your
obedience silent though it may be will
be one of those witnesses to others
above all honor your conscience if the
holy spirit is saying to you now don't
ask somebody else to take your shift or
this person then honor what the holy
spirit says to you and remember there
are a variety of fields that are not
labor but service to those who are in
need that must be done you think about
the care care of individuals who are
sick you think about some things that
must be done day by day and God does
bless our our participation in the
service of people in need let your
employer know respectfully and kindly
what your conviction is from God's word
and then don't don't back down from that
conviction do what's right and then be
the best impossible employee like Daniel
was so the worst thing somebody can say
about you is they obeyed their God even
when it was difficult and remember that
there are legal Protections in in this
country at least that direct employers
to accommodate your sincere belief if it
doesn't place an undue burden upon them
and in all things pray about it let God
lead you and if this is not the
direction that your question was
intended to be understood feel free to
submit it again and we'd be happy to
respond
excellent answer Daniel excellent uh
John Dinsey can you please explain Luke
chapter 18 verses 18 and 19.
very good I'll read that uh it's Luke 18
18 19 now a certain ruler asked him
saying good teacher in King James
version says good master I'm reading
from the new King James good good
teacher what shall I do to inherit
eternal life
so Jesus said to him why do you call me
good no one is good but one that is God
the way I'm looking at this I'm
understanding that you want to focus on
why do you call me good no one is good
but one that is God
um here we have this person that came to
Jesus the rulers calling him good
teacher and Jesus brings to him to his
attention you're calling me good what
are you really saying no one is good but
one that is God so he's bringing to his
mind are you are you really thinking are
you really analyzing or understanding
what you're calling me you're calling me
good and only one is good are you
recognizing me as the Son of God in
essence this is what we see here in this
scripture and uh we have in John chapter
10 verse 30 that Jesus says I and my
father are one so Jesus in essence is
saying the father is good I am good
because we are one
we have in Psalm 14 verse 2 and 3. that
tells us about uh
the way this is described the Lord
looked down from heaven upon the
children of men to see if there were any
that did understand and seek God they
are all gone aside they are all together
become filthy there's none that do it
good no not one so in essence human
beings you can say they're really not
good as God is Romans chapter 3 verse 10
through 12 it says as it is written
there is none righteous no not one
there's none who understand there's none
that who seeks after God they all have
all turned aside they have together
become unprofitable there's none who
does good no not one so God is good and
we are by his grace being transformed to
be like him Romans 3 2 3 23 says for all
have sinned and fall short of the glory
of God of the character of God but God
wants to do a work of transformation in
us this is why we need to abide in him
as it says in John 15 that we may by his
grace do all things Jesus says without
me you can do nothing and it is by his
grace that we can walk According To
Jesus Jesus says
that if any man shall come after me let
him take up his cross daily and follow
me
Psalm 119 verse 68 says talking about
God you are good and do good teach me
your statutes we should be willing to
learn of the Lord Psalm 86 5 for you
Lord are good and ready to forgive an
abundant in Mercy to all those who call
upon you
so I encourage you to come to the Lord
and that he can do a work of
transformation in your life
perhaps you want to ask another question
is what should I do to inherit eternal
life maybe that's the subject for
another question
ah that is a good subject for another
question
um Pastor Loma Kang should Seventh-day
Adventist Christians go to funerals and
weddings on the Sabbath day okay this is
a question that opens up a lot of doors
let me encourage you first thing to do
is look at one of the examples in the
earliest portion of the ministry of
Jesus his first miracle
turning water into wine at the wedding
of Cana matter of fact I had a privilege
when we went to the Bible lands I
performed a recommittal service in Cana
for all the couples that joined us when
we went on the uh the tour of the Bible
lands it was very very interesting and
we even bought some of the Jewish
non-alcoholic wine from Cana and brought
it home because of my wife and I
celebrating our anniversary it was a
beautiful place and we did a church
right there where we anticipated a
thought that the the miracle of Jesus
could not have been too far away from
here
well let me just answer this first in a
practical way than a scriptural way when
you read the Bible story one of the
context of weddings weddings sometimes
took as many as seven days weddings were
long celebrations that's why later on
the Feast of Tabernacles was referred to
as a seven-day celebration they
celebrated all the time and you may
remember Jesus brought the wine at the
end of the wedding so that there'll be
no doubt in anyone's mind that he didn't
provide the wine at the beginning and
therefore it fermented and by the end of
the wedding everybody was getting drunk
from the wine Jesus gave and the clear
indication was he saved the best for
last
but there is no sin to go to a funeral
or a wedding on the Sabbath and let me
tell you what I did once
when I was pastoring in the Fairfield
center of the Adventist Church we had a
wedding right after the church service
and a lot of people we discussed this at
our board and they said should we do
that well the person planning the
wedding said here's the reason behind it
they said I joined this church he was my
former life
and they described a very dark life and
the people I hung out with would not
come to church around Sabbath but they
would come to a wedding so they said if
we had the wedding right after the
service they'll be there for the service
and they'll see the wedding and the
church was packed that damn thing wow
man our church is full but this was an
inordinate for that day and I said
and then we transition from the closing
song we said now we're transitioning
into the wedding
now the wedding or the funeral is not
the issue it is what follows that
because these are both you can't tell
when a person is going to die you can't
plan and we've had a lot of weddings and
funerals people might say well they
could only do it on Saturday will you be
there neither of these events are a
desecrating event or Jesus would not
have been at the wedding at all
so we were allowed to let people see
because the wedding is the symbol that
God uses to describe his relationship
with the church what better day to do a
wedding on but it's what follows a
wedding and they had the wedding
reception in the evening after Sunset so
they were not involved in anything but
the principle is what I'd like to leave
with you and Paul illustrates this in
First Corinthians 10 31 therefore
whether you eat or drink
or whatever you do do all to the glory
of God
the funeral is to show your respects the
wedding is to support those who are
joining in holy matrimony the Sabbath is
not a day that excludes either one of
those it's what you do after that that
makes the difference amen amen nice
breakdown I never thought about it like
that excellent uh Daniel if I know that
God is all-powerful he knows the future
he made the past and present he knows
everything and he knows my heart's
desires do I have to ask him for
anything he gives me what I need and
what I deserve no matter what I pray and
ask for he gives what he knows is best
so do I even have to pray and ask for
anything
it is true that God knows your heart's
desire whether you voice it or not
nothing is hidden from him God knows so
the purpose of our prayers must be for
more than just informing god of what he
does not know he already knows our
thoughts and he also tells us not to
worry because he will take care of us
look at the birds of the air who do not
sow or store away in Barns or reap yet
your heavenly father feeds them aren't
you much more valuable than they and so
if God already knows your needs and your
desires and he already promises that he
will provide your needs according to his
riches and glory in Christ Jesus well
then why should I pray
and there's three answers I have to give
and the first one of them is simply
because he tells us to
and if that were all there was that
would be good enough God who knows what
I'm like knows what I need he tells me
that I need to pray and keep on praying
Philippians 4 verse 6 says to be anxious
about nothing but in everything with
prayer and supplication with
Thanksgiving let your requests be made
known to God there is this invitation
and command Matthew 7 verse 7 Jesus says
ask
and it will be given to you and the
Bible is full of people who spend their
time in prayer asking repeatedly and
Jesus tells us Luke 18 verse 1 that we
should pray and not lose heart not stop
the second response is that prayer is
more than just a transaction of sharing
information more than just a series of
questions to which God can reply yes or
no or maybe but it is about friendship
and honesty and drawing hearts together
so that they will be connected God loves
the people who he created and loves to
be in fellowship and communion with them
and so when we come in prayer we say
Lord here's my need that you already
know and here's my desire that you know
but as I talk about them to you I'm
saying Lord I want my expression of my
needs and desires to become more like
you I want my thoughts to reflect yours
and I want my desires to reflect yours
and not mine
and so as I ask the Holy Spirit to fill
me and as I spend time in God's word
Hebrews 4 12 says that the word of God
is living and active that it pierces
even the inmost parts of you Discerning
your very thoughts and we say God I want
you to be the one in charge of my very
thoughts this doesn't happen through a
hasty reading of the Bible nor a hasty
time of prayer but we spend time
listening to God's word and listening to
him because the goal of our prayer is
not that we can change God who is
all-knowing and all-powerful but that it
can change me so I can be like the God
who loves me and this is why recited
prayers are not very helpful because
they oftentimes don't really come from
the heart
uh the third response reason why we pray
is because there are blessings that God
intends and desires to give that he
cannot give to us if we do not will to
receive them if we don't have the desire
and the willingness and our asking
expresses that desire and willingness so
listen to John 1 verse 12 but as many
who received him that's a choice
to them he gave the right to become
children of God God invites you to ask
he says ask for the Holy Spirit we are
to ask for Godly wisdom that we have to
choose to receive we have to ask for the
forgiveness of sin that God offers
freely and we have to ask for God's
grace to give us strength to resist
temptation and this expresses our desire
to have it it is a privilege to come to
God In Prayer it's not a meaningless
powerless ritual it's not spiritual busy
work with a predetermined outcome nor is
it a cold and distant obligation but it
is a an experience of friendship and joy
and I pray that you will experience it
too and long for it and love it every
day amen it's so beautiful that God
wants to hear from us and that's that's
incredible uh brother Johnny I have been
in Seventh-day Adventist for 40 years
and still lack that perfect peace I
heard people talk about what am I
missing can you share some scriptures
with me
well we it would be good to be able to
talk to you to find out some of the
things that are maybe going on in your
life but
what can we look at as we consider this
question John 14 27 Jesus says peace I
leave with you my peace I give to you
so we have here this promise of Jesus
that he is giving us peace what should
we do if we do not
take this piece we will not have it what
is missing
perhaps the answer can be found in
Isaiah 26 verse 3 and 4 you will keep
him in perfect peace whose mind is
stayed on you so this there's a
requirement for us to enjoy the peace is
to have our minds stayed on God and it
says because he trusts in you so we
there's a need for us to trust the Lord
no matter what the circumstances are
because sometimes we look at the problem
and we worry and worry and worry and
this disturbs the peace that what God
wants to give us so you will keep him in
perfect perfect peace whose mind stayed
on you because he trusts in you trust in
the Lord with all your heart
and he says trust in the Lord forever
for in Jehovah the Lord is Everlasting
strength
Matthew 11 28-30 again here's another
one come to me all you who labor and are
heavy laden are you Laden with problems
of the world problems of life
Jesus says I will give you rest
so there's a believing aspect in this uh
of having this rest and having this
peace
take my yoke upon you and learn from me
so we must daily learn from Jesus this
is why he said If any man will come
after me let him take up his cross daily
and come after me so daily we should be
focusing on Jesus the more we focus on
Jesus the greater will be our peace and
he says for I am gentle and lowly in
heart and you will find rest for your
souls it doesn't say maybe find rest or
there's a possibility or some fine rest
no you will find rest
in Jesus Jesus says from my yoke is easy
and my burden is light
so I bring you now to Hebrews chapter 12
verse 1 and 2. wherefore seeing also we
are confessed about with so great a
cloud of witnesses let us lay aside
every weight those things that are
keeping the peace from you gotta lay
them aside and the sin which doth so
easily beset us
and let us turn let us run with patience
the race that is set before us how
should we do that looking unto Jesus the
author and finisher of our faith who for
the joy that was set before him endure
the cross despising the shame and is set
down at the right hand of the Throne of
God so looking unto Jesus we can have
that peace by uh keeping our minds
stayed on him we can have that peace and
the more the closer you get to Christ
the greater will be your peace Jesus is
waiting with open arms that's why the
Bible says in Revelation 3 20 behold I
stand at the door and knock If any man
hears my voice and opens the door I will
come into him and sup with him and he
with me open the door to Jesus begin
that Journey amen amen true peace exists
in the presence of God Amen Pastor Wilma
King how could Jesus have been with God
at creation when he wasn't even born
till 4 000 years later
wow I love that question but it's so
simple to answer it
the the name Jesus let's start with that
Jesus is the English or the word that
was given after being transliterated
from the Latin but the but the Hebrew
word is Yeshua
uh you find matter of fact I have at
home a Hebrew Bible uh Hebrew Old and
New Testament somebody gifted it to me
it's beautiful to see uh you find in the
Old Testament Joshua or Yeshua there's
no J the Yeshua so that designated name
Jesus call his name Jesus for he will
save his people from their sins is the
name he was given in his Earthly
condescension to carry out the ministry
but look at the words of Jesus himself
he was in the very beginning you find in
John 17 5 these words and now O Father
glorify me together with yourself with
the glory which I had with you before
the world was so you find you said how
could he have been there but he wasn't
born until 4 000 years later his cut his
ministry his Earthly ministry didn't
begin until 4 000 years later when the
fullness of time had come God sent forth
his son he sent him where John 3 16 for
God that He gave His only begotten son
John 3 17 for God sent not a son into
the world
where was he before that he wasn't in
the world see he wasn't in the world he
came into the world through Mary he took
on human flesh but he existed quite
before that John 1 verse 1 to 3 in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
with God and the Word was God he was in
the beginning with God all things were
made through him and without him nothing
was made that was made and verse 14 says
the word became flesh and dwelt among us
but the greatest evidence we find here
is in Hebrews chapter 1 and I'm going to
go back to Psalm
Psalm 90 verse 1 and 2. let's look at
some comparisons here
Lord you have been our Dwelling Place in
all generations before the mountains
were brought forth wherever you are
wherever you had formed the earth and
the world even from Everlasting to
Everlasting you are God
now the question is who's David talking
about let's go ahead and connect it he
mentions this again in Psalm 45 or 6
you're thrown o God is forever and ever
a scepter of righteousness is the
scepter of your kingdom what God is he
talking about let's let Hebrews make it
clear Hebrews one verse 8 to 10 but to
the son he says your throne oh God is
forever and ever a scepter of
righteousness is the scepter of your
kingdom the father is calling the son
God he's quoting Psalm 45 verse 6 but
verse 9 says you have loved
righteousness and hated lawlessness
therefore God your God has anointed you
with oil of gladness more than your
companions in verse 10 and you Lord in
the beginning laid the foundations of
the earth and the heavens are the work
of your hands so he was in the beginning
his father even declared that you're
thrown o goddess forever and he calls
that he says that about a son and the
glory that they shared on Earth was the
glory they had before the world was ever
made that's a short version yes yes you
definitely cut it down for us there I
love the repeat and enlarged theme that
we see playing out in the Bible real
quick
if you're going to study the Bible with
someone how do you approach that how do
you start with that individual okay
well anybody John I don't know I'm not
good John you want to start or Daniel to
study the word of God with somebody I I
believe one of the best places to start
is with the sacrifice that Jesus came to
make for us getting a glimpse of Jesus
and sets the good foundation to
understand that whatever situation we
face in this world
through his grace we have eternal life
amen
do I think that's a great place to start
if there's one thing that you can be
passionate about it's talking about
Jesus and you know there's there's four
different gospels and each one of them
speaks to different people letting you
know that that regardless of what kind
of person you're talking about what
their needs are uh you're going to find
a way to reach their heart by starting
there establishing that that number one
we have a need and there's a solution
amen amen there is a solution and it can
be found in the word of God what about
you
I think it's wonderful begin with Jesus
study Jesus and with him and you'll
understand how beautiful the father and
the son are together amen amen well I
hope that you've been writing down some
of these verses that have been shared
and jotting down some future questions
we're going to take a brief break show
you how you can submit those questions
and we will be right back
if you're enjoying our 3abian Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3ab in Bible q a for answers from
God's word
welcome back I can't believe our time is
just about up but I'd like to open the
floor for any final thoughts that you
guys may have
Daniel yes I just want to share one more
text thinking about prayer that Psalm 26
verse 1 and 2 the prayer starts
vindicate me O Lord that's a request but
verse 2 then says examine Me O Lord and
prove me try my mind and my heart that
prayer says God it's not just me telling
you I'm inviting you to look inside and
talk to me change my life through this
amen amen where I like to point to Luke
chapter 24 and Luke chapter 24 there's
the experience of two individuals
walking after Jesus was crucified and
Jesus joined and said what are you guys
talking about they were sad and uh Jesus
was talking to them and it says in Luke
24 31 and 31 and 32 and their eyes were
open and they knew him and he vanished
out of their sight and they said to one
another didn't that our hearts burn
within us while he talked with us by the
way and while he opened to us the
scriptures Jesus is willing to do that
for us today but we need to spend time
with him amen and I want to quickly
speak again to the activities on the set
but the wedding and funeral in
particular both of these are events the
Lord did not ordain funerals because he
didn't want anyone to die but we are
living in a world where death and life
are just so side by side in the between
life and death and weddings okay some
people's lives are enhanced by weddings
uh other people have experiences that
are not so great but if you approach
everything with the idea that Christ can
be exalted I think one of the things
that Daniel talked about in reference to
making choices about your entertainment
will the Lord be exalted through that
and the principle in John 12 verse 32
and if I be lifted up from the earth
I'll draw all men to myself let your
activity draw people to Christ amen amen
thank you all so much thank you for
joining us study God's word grow in his
likeness and you will never regret it
God bless you
[Music]
thank you